c'est le ministre de l'éducation qui a
annoncé la nouvelle se félicitant
d'avoir écouté la population
[Applaudissements]
13000 personnes ont participé à des
consultations publiques cet hiver des
parents des enseignants et des
chercheurs ont vivement critiqué le plan
du gouvernement
on a découvert comme j'ai dit que ce
n'est pas le meilleur choix pour
tous nos élèves alors
on ne va pas le faire
pourtant le Premier ministre blending
était fermement convaincu que son plan
était le meilleur soit commencé à
démanteler l'immersion française dès
septembre et mettre en place un nouveau
programme offrant l'éducation en
français la moitié de la journée ce qui
est beaucoup moins que l'immersion
c'était une bonne nouvelle c'est super
et ses filles sont soulagées d'apprendre
que le programme d'immersion reste en
place les filles s'expriment déjà bien
en français depuis qu'elles sont en
immersion leurs parents des anglophones
estiment qu'elles auront de meilleures
chances de trouver un bon emploi en
étant bilingue Jacob le dernier de la
famille doit faire son entrée en
première année en septembre soulager
parce que maintenant mon frère va aller
et beaucoup d'autres personnes et je ne
vois pas comme oublier le français et
les choses comme ça je me sens beaucoup
moins anxieuse et c'est comme tout d'un
coup je suis comme plein d'espoir à
Frédéric tonne les parties d'opposition
applaudissent aussi la décision du
gouvernement je suis soulagée que ce
changement ne vont pas continuer
finalement le gouvernement a écouté
allez néoprendu quoi
qui ont clairement dit c'est pas un plan
que nous voulons pour notre province
c'est l'ancien ministre de l'Éducation
Dominique Cordy qui avait révélé
l'automne dernier les projets du
gouvernement X de mettre fin au
programme d'immersion c'était une
mauvaise direction je suis heureux qu'il
recule la même temps il fait énormément
de dommage j'en ai un système
d'éducation c'est dans notre ministre de
démissionner
le nouveau ministre de l'Éducation
Biogen était seul il s'est aussi engagé
à améliorer les cours de français pour
les anglophones qui ne sont pas en
immersion ici Michel Bridou Radio-Canada
mountain